when you're studying chemistry you'll
often see reactions in fact you always
see reactions for example if you have
hydrogen gas
it's a diatomic molecule because
hydrogen bonds with itself in the
gaseous state
plus iodine gas
i2 that's also in the gaseous state it's
very easy to desert oh you know if you
put them together they're going to react
and form the product if you have well
you have two moles of hydrogen two moles
of iodine so it's going to form two
moles of
hydrogen
iodide
and that's all
nice and neat and it makes it seem like
it's a very clean thing that happens
without much fuss but we know that that
isn't the reality and we also know that
this doesn't happen just instantly it's
not like you can just take some hydrogen
put it with some some some iodine and it
just magically turns into hydrogen
iodide that there's some process going
on that you know these gaseous state
particles are bouncing around and
somehow they must bounce into each other
and break bonds that they were in before
and form new ones and that's what we're
going to study now and this whole study
of how the reaction progresses and the
rates of the reactions is called
kinetics
which is a very fancy word but you're
probably familiar with it because we've
talked a lot about kinetic energy
kinetics
kinetics which is just the study of the
rate of of reactions how fast do they
happen and how do they happen so let's
just in our minds come up with a
intuitive way that hydrogen and iodine
can combine so let's think about what
hydrogen looks like so if we get our
periodic table out hydrogen's got one
valence electron so if they have two
hydrogen atoms they can share them with
each other and then iodine
iodine has seven valence electrons so if
they share one they get complete as well
so let's just review that right now so
hydrogen
this hydrogen might have one
uh well will have one electron out there
and then you could have another hydrogen
that has another electron out there and
then if they form a bond they share this
this hydrogen can pretend like he has
this electron this hydrogen can predom
like she has that electron and then
they're happy they both feel like
they've completed their 1s shell same
thing on the iodine side
where you have two iodines they both
have seven valence electrons
they're halogens you know that already
halogens are the group seven elements
so they have seven electrons this guy's
got one here this guy's got one here if
this guy can pretend like he's got that
electron he's happy he has eight valence
electrons if this guy can pretend like
he's got that one same thing so there's
a bond right here and this is why
hydrogen is a diatomic
molecular gas and this is why iodine is
the same
now when you when they're in the gaseous
state
you have a bunch of these things that
are moving around bumping into each
other i'll do it like this so the
hydrogen might look something like this
the hydrogen which these two atomic
spheres that are bonded together they
have these electrons in between that are
keeping them bonded the iodine might
look something like this it's a much
bigger molecule
where it's bonded together like this
it's also sharing some electrons in a
covalent bond everything's probabilistic
so in order for these two molecules to
turn to this somehow these bonds have to
be broken and new bonds have to be
formed and what has to happen is that
these guys there's a ton of these guys i
mean i could draw a bunch of them
or i could copy and paste
so there's a bunch of
there's a bunch of
hydrogen molecules around and
some of these
iodine gas molecules around
so what has to happen in order for us to
get the hydrogen iodide is they have to
collide and have to collide in exactly
the right way so let's say this guy
which i could show let's say he's moving
this is neat i'm just dragging and
dropping but he's moving he has to he
has to hit this hydrogen molecule just
right and maybe just right if he just
happens to hit it and bounce it with
enough energy then all of a sudden let's
say we get to this point right here
these electrons are going to say hey you
know i you know it's nice to be shared
this way we're in a stable configuration
we're filling the 1s shell but look at
this there's this ion iodine that's
close by and they really want me they're
they're much more electronegative than
me the hydrogen so maybe they're kind of
attracted here they don't know whether
they want to be here between that
hydrogen and this right here between
that and so they they kind of enter this
higher energy state and similarly you
know these guys they say hey wouldn't it
be nicer i don't have to be here i could
kind of go back to back home to my to my
home atom if this guy comes in here
because then we're going to have then
we're going to have eight valence
electrons and the same thing is
happening here
and this complex right here this this
this kind of you know right when the
collision happens this is actually this
is actually a state it's the high energy
state of the transition state of the
reaction and this is called an activated
complex
activated complex
activated
complex sometimes
you know i just drew it kind of visually
but it could be you could draw it like
this so hydrogen has a covalent bond
with another hydrogen
and then here comes along
some iodine that has a covalent bond
with some other iodine but all of a
sudden these guys like to bond as well
so they start forming so they there's
kind of a you know there's there's a
little bit of an attraction on that side
too so this is another way of drawing
the activation complex but this is a
high energy state because in order for
the electrons the way you can think of
it to kind of go from that bond to this
bond or this bond to that bond or to go
back they have to higher enter into a
higher energy state a less energy stable
energy state than they were before but
they do that if there's enough energy
because you can go from
from so you're going from
both of these things separate let me
just draw them separate so you have both
of them separate
you have the hydrogen separate plus
the iodine separate
they go to this which is a higher energy
state but if they can get to that higher
energy state if there's enough energy
for the collision and they hit they have
enough kinetic energy when they hit in
the right orientation then
from this
activated complex or this higher energy
state it will then go to the lowest
energy state and the lowest energy state
is
the hydrogen iodide
whoops
i want to draw the iodide
and then the hydrogen
and then the hydrogen this is actually
this is actually a lower energy state
than this but in order in order to get
here you have to go through a higher
energy state and i could do that with an
energy diagram so if we say that
let's say the x-axis is the progression
of the reaction
progression
progression of the reaction
and actually you know we don't know how
fast it's progressing but this you can
kind of view it as time in some on some
dimension and let's say this is the
potential energy
i want to draw thicker lines
say this is the potential energy
right there let me make this line
thicker as well
so this is the potential
potential energy
so initially we're at this this this
reality and we can kind of view it as
the combined potential energy so this
where eventually we start off here and
this is the
h2 plus i2
and a lower potential energy is when
we're in the hydrogen iodide so this is
the lower potential energy down here
lower potential energy down here this is
the 2
h i
right but to get here we have to enter
this higher activation energy where the
electrons have to get they have to have
some energy to kind of be able to at
least figure out what they want to do
with their lives and so you have to add
energy to the system you don't always
have to add it but if it doesn't happen
spontaneously you're gonna have to add
some energy to the system
to get to this activated state
right so this is when we are at
this thing right here
we're there so some energy has to be in
the system and this energy the
difference between the energy we're at
when we were just hydrogen molecules and
iodine molecules and the energy we have
to get to to get this activated state
this distance right here
this is the activation energy
activation energy if we're able to to
get to somehow put enough energy in the
system then this thing will happen
they'll collide with enough energy and
bonds will be broken and reformed
activation energy sometimes it's written
as ea energy of activation and in the
future we'll maybe do reactions where we
actually measure the activation energy
but the important thing is to
conceptually understand that it that
it's there that that things just don't
spontaneously go from here to here and i
won't go in deeply into catalysts right
now but you've probably heard of the
word catalyst or something being
catalyzed and that's something some
other agent some other thing in the
reaction so right now
so right now we're doing
we have h2 plus i2
yielding 2 h hydrogen iodides
now you could have a catalyst and i'll
just say plus c
plus c and i actually don't know what a
good catalyst would be for this reaction
and it the how a catalyst operates is it
can actually operate in many many
different ways so that's why i don't
want to do it in this video but what a
catalyst is is something that doesn't
change it doesn't get consumed in the
reaction the catalyst was there before
the reaction the catalyst is there after
the reaction but what it does is it
makes the reaction happen or either
faster or it lowers the amount of energy
for the reaction to happen which is kind
of the same thing so if you have a
catalyst then this activation energy
will be
lower and what it does is it makes it it
might easily it might be some molecule
that allows some other transition state
that has less of a potential energy so
that you require less heat or less
concentration of the molecules for them
to bump into each other in the right
direction to get to that other state so
you require less energy
so given how we understand
how these kinetics occur these molecules
interact with each other what do you
think are the things that will drive
whether a reaction happens or not i mean
we already know that if we have a
positive catalyst or something there's
something called a negative catalyst
that will actually slow down a reaction
but if we have a positive catalyst
it lowers
a positive catalyst obviously it lowers
the activation energy so this
so this makes reaction faster
reaction
faster
more molecules are going to bump into
each other just right to be able to get
over this hump because the hump will be
lower when you have a catalyst
also if you increase the concentration
right if you put if you increase your
concentration
of molecules
if the concentration goes up then you
just have more stuff to bump into each
other
right there's just the likelihood
everything is probabilistic when you
know when people write these these
reaction equations it all seems nice and
simple and very clear and it happens but
no in the real world
you just have things bumping into each
other and you know when we when we do
biology videos it'll be fascinating to
talk about because all of every
biological process is really just a
chemical process
and it's really just the byproduct of of
all of these things bumping into each
other and you can imagine the more
concentration you have of the things
that need to bump into each other the
more likely you're going to get just
that perfect bump and that perfect
amount of kinetic energy for the
reaction to happen
and actually i'll make a little other
note here this reaction you might say
okay i have some let's say i'm at this
energy how do i ever get over this how
does this ever react well remember in a
gas the kinetic energies of all the
molecules they're not uniform some gases
have
some molecules will have higher kinetic
energy some will have lower temperature
just gives you the average so there's
always some probability that two maybe
high kinetic energy molecules will bump
into each other just perfectly
surpass the kinetic so they have enough
kinetic energy to get into the
activation state and then they can go to
the lower stage which is the hydrogen
iodide so even at a at a at all
temperatures this will occur but
obviously if you increase the
temperature if you increase the
temperature that reaction is more likely
so that's the other one so temperature
temperature is actually probably the
biggest
temperature is probably the single
biggest thing that will make the
reaction happen faster
so all of these things you want higher
temperature higher reaction
and then if you just want to think about
the molecules itself
if if you have molecules where their
original bonds are weak
they're more likely to be able to
interact and there's other things you
could talk about the molecular shape how
available certain atoms are to interact
with other atoms and that really becomes
significant when we start going into
biology and then the last one you
probably realize this is just the
surface area
if you increase the surface area so we
were just doing gas gas interactions
which almost by definition have pretty
good surface area interactions but if
the surface area goes up then the
reaction also goes up the reaction rate
and how do you think about that we'll
think about the reaction of
think about the reaction of you know
we've done this multiple times sodium
chloride
solid so solid salt plus
liquid water
leads to
sodium well we can think of it a lot of
different ways but we could think of it
as
sodium ion aqueous
plus chloride
anions is a cation anion aqueous
so it gets dissolved and how does that
happen if you have a big block of ice or
not ice of salt
if you have a big i'll do salt in gray
if you have a big block of salt in there
and you have you know so there's a bunch
of sodium and chloride
atoms
in it
and you have water all around it
the water is only going to be able to
interact with the surface molecules and
slowly dissolve away the salt slowly
make make polar bonds these are actually
well the polar dipole bonds with the
different the different sodium or or
chloride
ions but if you were to break this up
into smaller cubes
if you were to break it up or really
crush it into really small pieces
then all of a sudden the surface area
that the water molecules can interact
with it can actually interact with more
of the sodium chloride so the reaction
will happen faster so surface air you
increase the surface area of interaction
and you'll also increase the reaction
rate if you're trying to do it with two
fluids what you could do is you can kind
of spray one fluid into the other so you
have little droplets so you also
increase the surface area so anyway this
is kind of an introduction to the idea
of kinetics but hopefully it gives you a
sense that you know these reactions and
i want you to really think about
chemistry this way not think about it as
oh it's just some formula i have to
remember that these really are bumps and
and bruises between atoms as
probabilistic and it's messy and and we
really have to think about what will
make it more likely that these things
collide in just the perfect way for the
reactions to happen